bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7 8 sport tout de
suite le sommaire
course automobile au départ officiel de
la 25e édition du Rallye des Gazelles a
été donné ce samedi depuis Nice nous
avons sué sur ce premier jour d'épreuve
les Trappistes Séverine soleil Laurence
se battala course à pied la 35e édition
de la course du printemps été programmée
ce dimanche dans les rues de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux tous les détails
dans cette édition handball le chêne
s'est imposé de justesse 31 à 30 sur son
terrain contre Gennevilliers vous
entendrez dans ce magazine la réaction
du capitaine Marc béari et puis enfin
démission nous reviendrons sur les
résultats du week-end
je vous le disais dans les titres le
départ de la 25e édition du Rallye des
Gazelles a été donné depuis Nice ce
samedi parmi 316 concurrentes les deux
trapis se sont élancés au bord de leur
4x4 nous les avons suivi jusqu'à la
Promenade des Anglais le montage est
signé romain ruspini les images
williamel
Séverine Soula et Laurence de trappistes
se sont lancés le défi de participer au
Rallye des Gazelles une course
automobile réservée aux femmes qui se
déroulent du 25 mars au 4 avril dans le
désert marocain mercredi dernier avant
leur départ la ville de trappes à tenue
à saluer leur performance une
cinquantaine d'écoliers venus à la
rencontre devant la mairie les deux
coéquipiers ont présentés à cette
occasion leur voiture et le concept du
rallye aux jeunes étudiants
et puis ça fait monter un peu la
pression en se disant que voilà le
départ approche on est enfin prête enfin
voilà c'est un projet qu'on a depuis un
an et demi donc ça se concrétise et donc
voilà c'est c'est vraiment enfin c'est
aussi les enfants avec qui nos enfants
sont à l'école etc donc c'est vraiment
impressionnant
participer à cette aventure humaine
Séverine et Laurence vont devoir quitter
trappes pendant près de trois semaines
une séparation compliquée à vivre pour
leurs proches je suis
contemporaine c'est un peu dur j'espère
qu'elle reviendra avec tous ces morceaux
de jambes tout une fois les dernières
valises bouclées direction Nice pour nos
deux trappistes le départ de cette 25e
édition du Rallye des Gazelles sera
donnée le samedi depuis la légendaire
Promenade des Anglais dans la Baie des
Anges les participants embarqueront
ensuite pour le Maroc
316 gazelles venues de 13 pays sont sur
la ligne de départ cette année les
participantes peuvent conduire des
voitures des quads des buggies ou des
motos nos deux 40 néer Laurent céverin
ont opté pour un 4x4 tout terrain pour
mettre toutes les chances de notre côté
c'est des pneus
avec
des crampons assez modestes finalement
pour un 4x4 qui nous permettront à la
fois d'aller sur la piste mais aussi
affronter les dunes et le sable très mou
donc le moteur donc un 4 litres 2
si c'est l'Indre turbo compressé pour
affronter tous types de terrain et tout
type de difficultés c'est un moteur à
toute épreuve qui a fait ses preuves
depuis de très nombreuses années c'est
un véhicule qui n'est plus tout jeune en
fait qu'on a loué néanmoins c'est un
véhicule qui continue à tourner qui a
une mécanique assez je dirais simple
d'abord et
increvable trivialement parlant on dit
souvent souvent increvable voilà c'est
les rois du désert globalement à
l'intérieur de la voiture un dispositif
permet au gazelle d'être géolocalisé en
permanence par les organisateurs
objectifs rendre la course la plus sûr
possible c'est cet instrument qui
s'appelle le thératrip on a plusieurs
boutons qui nous permettent soit de
communiquer comme un interphone avec
l'organisation en cas de difficulté un
autre rouge qui nous permet de
communiquer et de transmettre à
l'organisation une information comme
quoi on est en difficulté au niveau
médical et ensuite donc le bouton vert
que vous avez sur le terraribe qui va
nous permettre de communiquer avec
l'organisation encore pour demander de
l'aide dites techniques en n'étant pas
sur le rallye on a une casse mécanique
on les appelle on ne peut pas réparer
nous-mêmes on les appelle il nous
rejoigne sur le parcours les conditions
risquent d'être une nouvelle fois
éprouvante au programme réveil à 4h tous
les matins et conduites entre 12 et 15
heures par jour la compétition se fera
sans l'assistance de GPS ou de téléphone
pour leur première participation nos
deux trappistes risquent de souffrir
dans le désert marocain
il faut absolument écouter et ça je
voulais répéter souvent les règles les
consignes être à l'heure au briefing
écouter consciencieusement prendre en
note si vous arrivez à faire ça ça sera
top parce qu'il y aura plus aucun
problème après il va vouloir vous armer
de courage on en a beaucoup de belles
tailles
mais je crois que vous devez y arriver
il y en a d'autres qui sont arrivés
avant vous il y a pas de raison que vous
n'arriviez pas au bout c'est très
important d'aller récupérer comme vous
avez la chance vous amusez partagez à
voir ce moment de joie parce que à
quelque part vous avez travaillé fort et
c'est pas facile mais Dominique A
organise quelque chose de fantastique
pour créer ces moments d'humanité c'est
vraiment humain alors amusez-vous avant
de monter dans leur 4x4 et de prendre le
départ de cette 25e édition les gazelles
ont participé à une Zumba géante
organisée par le rallye une heure avant
le départ un moment convivial pour leur
permettre d'évacuer le stress des
dernières semaines d'entraînement
il faut l'événement musical terminé
direction les véhicules pour les 316
concurrentes les baroudeuses doivent
embarquer à 7 pour rejoindre le Maroc le
départ symbolique de la course est
donnée par le maire de Nice Christian
Estrosi une grande aventure commence
pour les gazelles les participantes
reviendront sans aucun doute avec des
souvenirs plein la tête
Séverine soulay Laurence se battle à la
débute le Rallye des Gazelles au Maroc
ce mercredi nous fera un point sur les
performances des yvelinoises et deux
trappistes pour la compétition dans les
prochaines éditions du 7 8 sport une
autre gazelle originaire des Yvelines a
pris le départ de cette 25e édition la
plaisiroise Laura boughan et vinoise est
en binôme avec la Niçoise Kate Williams
nous l'avons rencontré dans la baie des
anges
nous sommes avec Laura boughan sur le
Rallye des Gazelles ici à Nice alors
pourquoi vous êtes vous engagé dans
cette compétition nous soutenons une
association qui s'appelle lampa c'est
une association monégasque qui lutte
contre la maladie d'Alzheimer elle avait
besoin de deux gazelles ma coéquipière
pilote fait partie de l'association et
nous sommes amis et donc elle m'a
contacté pour ce challenge incroyable
qui est Rallye des Gazelles je serai la
navigatrice donc tout ce qui est degré
plan il faut savoir que c'est un rallye
sans GPS avec des cartes du désert donc
particulière à lire nous sommes très
très motivés nous sommes toutes les deux
des challengeuses et donc vous êtes
originaire des Yvelines tout à fait je
suis née dans l'Essonne mais j'ai grandi
depuis l'âge de 3 ans dans les Yvelines
tout d'abord à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
puis après j'ai fait Poissy et là je
suis à plaisir et qu'est-ce qui vous a
rapproché avec Kate Williams du coup
elle est Nice où vous êtes des Yvelines
et quel est le lien en fait on a
travaillé toutes les deux sur un très
grand projet pour Monaco on a travaillé
trois ans c'était pour l'urbanisation en
mer et on a vu qu'on était capable de
tenir une pression incroyable vis-à-vis
du gouvernement monégasque on avait des
réunions très souvent ça ça nous alliés
on s'est dit que pour un rallye fallait
extrêmement s'entendre on est deux dans
une voiture toute la journée et si il y
a pas cette entente là je pense que
c'est des mauvais points pour l'équipe
qui ne s'entend pas et nous on s'entend
vraiment à merveille elle a pensé à moi
tout de suite quand son association lui
a dit il faut qu'on fasse le rallye car
on a un centre d'Alzheimer qui s'ouvre à
Essaouira le jour de l'arrivée des
Gazelles donc c'est c'est un coût
médiatique en fait qu'on soit là pour
faire parler de l'association récolter
des dons et avancer sur la maladie dans
la recherche mais aussi les petits les
petites choses qu'il y a de le quotidien
des gens qui soulagent les personnes qui
qui ont dans leur famille des personnes
malades et justement ce lien avec votre
coéquipière c'est ça peut-être là qui va
faire la différence sur ce rallye je
pense il y a des coéquipières qui ne se
connaissent pas qui se sont chercher sur
internet parce qu'elles avaient besoin
d'une coéquipière du cicatrice d'une
pilote et nous c'est notre gros point
fort et quels sont vos objectifs sur ce
rallye alors on a un média qui s'appelle
Nice-Matin qui nous ça sponsorisé et
grâce à ce média on peut participer à un
challenge qui nous permet si on est les
premières de ce concours la médiatique
de gagner 15000 euros donc qui va bien
sûr pas à nous mais à l'association donc
ça ça nous motive énormément après c'est
notre premier rallye on n'est pas des
pilotes du coup on se met un challenge
parce qu'on aime mais on se fixe pas
d'être d'arriver en premier c'est très
difficile il y a des filles qui font ça
depuis 10 ans nous c'est notre première
année mais voilà on est challengeus donc
on y croit quand même et donc vous allez
partir dans quelques heures est-ce que
vous êtes prêtes oui on est prête ça y
est la voiture est bien bien chargée on
est prête heureuse on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour réussir merci Laura Bouillane
merci à vous et
à toutes les Y
Ines après la course automobile on passe
à la course à pied
la traditionnelle course du printemps
était programmée ce dimanche matin à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux le départ a été
donné depuis le complexe sportif des
pyramides plus de 600 personnes ont
participé à cette 35e édition le montage
est signé avec Xavier jalain
la 35ème édition de la course du
printemps était programmée ce dimanche
matin dans les rues de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux le départ des 15
km était donné depuis le complexe
sportif des pyramides les cours se sont
ensuite dirigés vers la forêt de Trappes
revenir vers la rue du Mail de chênefeld
j'ai trouvé que le parcours était quand
même assez roulant très roulant même et
il y avait des passages très
intéressants au niveau de la
récupération
et puis ce qui était intéressant surtout
c'était le mélange entre les courses en
forêt sur des chemins et des portions
plus
urbaines type
root bitume et ça c'était très
intéressant c'est un parcours assez
roulant après faut aimer les lignes
droites c'est c'est il y a pas trop de
virage donc des grandes lignes droites
de 2-3 km faut aimer donc c'est pour moi
c'est des difficultés qu'il y a c'est à
dire que les gens qui vont vite ils
aiment ça parce que il y a pas de côtes
ça va très vite après faut aimer courir
sur les grandes lignes droites cette
année plus de 600 personnes ont
participé à cette édition beaucoup ont
souffert dans les longues lignes droites
du parcours moi ça a été mais en
revanche il y a quelqu'un un autre
concurrent pas loin de l'arrivée qui m'a
tendu la main pour que je tape dedans et
puis du coup ça leur fait repartir
c'était très bien
de au niveau du moral de bien de se
motiver voilà c'est important parce qu'à
un moment donné j'avoue la morale est un
peu baissée donc le mental c'est
important aussi le record de l'épreuve
est tombé pendant cette journée Adrien
guillaumart du club de Suresnes a
terminé la course du printemps en 49
minutes et 38 secondes le dernier record
était à 51 minutes 04 donc à Grégory
cheval qui est quelqu'un de la région et
là il a été battu il est à 49-38 je
crois c'est quelque chose d'énorme sur
15 km c'est énorme quoi ça veut dire
c'est là on est à 18 et demi presque 19
de moyenne c'est ce qui est assez
impressionnant vu le succès rencontré
une nouvelle fois cette année une 36e
édition va être organisée en 2016
on passe maintenant aux autres résultats
du week-end en National 3 Le Chesnay
deuxième du classement pour le coup
d'envoi a souffert lors de son match
contre le dixième Aubervilliers
bousculer pendant la partie les verres
ont dû serrer le jeu en fin de rencontre
pour conserver leur avantage score final
31-30 on écoute le capitaine de l'équipe
du Chesnay marque béari
ça match on a on a eu du mal à gérer on
a géré une première mi-temps
intéressante deuxième mi-temps ils nous
ont mis un petit peu la pression parce
qu'on a des jeunes on a en manque un peu
certains joueurs cadres et après je
pense qu'on s'est mis en difficulté tout
seul quoi mais c'est un match qui montre
quand qu'on a le l'envie qu'on veut
aller de l'avant et que on essaie de
jouer quelque chose d'intéressant cette
victoire contre Aubervilliers a permis
au Chesnay de conserver sa deuxième
place au classement les hommes de Yanis
Norbert restent également au contact de
l'île les leaders Lille une équipe qui
les affront le week-end prochain à
l'extérieur c'est la fin de ce 7 8 sport
j'étais très heureux de le présenter et
de vous enfin merci de m'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau magazine très bonne soirée
sur tvfils à 78